as you may or may not know we're kind of
fans of barry at collider
yeah no yeah
yeah little bit um i have to ask you how
has it been going filming season three
what can you tease people about it
uh it's going really well i mean we have
a month left of shooting um
everybody's been
great
and um
i don't know if i could tease really
anything because so much
stuff happens we had some people
come in and shoot stuff we've been in
the other seasons and
yesterday actually they came in and they
have just a bit kind of cameo part this
season
and um i showed them a still from the
first episode
and they were shots
and they went whoa what and i was like
yeah
you know so
that was that was a fun reaction so i'm
interested to see what people think
about it
um how many episodes are you directing
um
i'm directing five of them and alex is
directing three
uh is it okay so it's an eight season uh
it's eight episodes for the season
yeah um
i know that uh you wrote you guys wrote
all of season four during the pandemic
how did the
writing of season four possibly impact
season three in terms of you're like oh
we need to tweak this to make this whole
yeah a hundred percent that's what
happened is we would we mapped out
season four and then
and then
went back and started laying stuff in
season three that could be in season
four and uh
it was really helpful it was kind of
like a great way of i mean we season
three we end up kind of fully
overhauling a lot of elements of it
because we've written four so
um
it was it was good
yeah uh i got to stop there i'm just
gonna say man you know how you know how
excited we are for barry and uh you know
i wish you nothing but the best and you
know seeing you man thank you guys for
all the the great uh
love for the show over at clyder it's a
thing that we
yeah it's it's in the edit room it's
it's me and alec aida rogers our
producer everybody will be like you see
what collider said so it's always uh so
thank you guys
yeah the best part though is i'm glad we
didn't uh jump on the bandwagon it like
once it got successful do you know what
i mean you guys were into it like from
the get-go so it was really nice